[MUSIC PLAYING]
BERNICE FOKUM: Even
though I love so,
so many things on Princeton's
campus, what I especially loved
was the opportunities that
they gave us to see the world.
So my semester that I spent
at the University of Havana
in Cuba was one of, by far,
my favorite experiences
at Princeton.
TIEN CHEN: I really enjoyed
turning in my thesis.
KEVIN CHAI: Performing on stage
with the BAC Dance Company.
CHARISSA SHEN:
When I would emcee
at Princeton Faith in
Action's weekly meeting
called Encounter.
MIRA MEHTA: My friends.
DYLAN BOWMAN: Going undefeated
in Ivy League freshman
year, Princeton soccer team.
WILLIAM GILPIN: Go camping
in rural Pennsylvania
for a weekend.
TORY ROBERTS: Playing on
the varsity softball team.
CHRIS CLEMENT: A lot of parties.
a lot of people came out,
and everybody just really
had a great time.
NOAH APTHORPE: Being able to
stay on campus over the summer
to do independent research.
DEBERLY KAUFFMAN:
After Dean's Date,
when I stayed up late
with a bunch of friends
playing Apples to Apples.
DRAGOS POTIRNICHE:
Physics research,
and collaborating
with my adviser,
and with post-docs
and other researchers.
SUNNY XU: Handing in
my thesis, knowing
that all those months of
hard work finally paid off.
PATRICK ROCHE: Getting to
go abroad, sort of spring
break my sophomore year,
to Rome and Pompeii.
DAYNA LI: Going on the
global seminar to Kenya.
LUCY LEE: Handing
in my senior thesis!
JENNIFER GREENE: Walking
through the gates
on Nassau as a freshman.
GINA TRIOLO: Both
being on campus
and the semester I
spent abroad in London,
I've been able to
interact with people
of so many different backgrounds
and different places all
the world, that I never thought
I would have the opportunity
to do before I came here.
ELISABETH POWELL:
The relationships
that I've forged
with my professors,
that I know will continue
for the rest of my life.
They are truly
mentors and friends.
JOHN MCNAMARA: The opportunity
to come here and meet people
from incredibly
diverse backgrounds,
and be able to work
one-on-one with faculty.
And build these relationships
that I think are going to last,
far beyond when I walk
out of FitzRandolph Gate,
I think is an
unbelievable opportunity.
ADAM MASTROIANNI: There was
a night early in my freshman
year, when I was just sitting
around, and all of a sudden,
there's these nine
people in red shirts
all banging and
screaming at my door.
And I open it up, and
they tell me to run.
And I'm running, and I'm
halfway across campus
before I realize I
got into Quickfire,
which is an improv comedy group.
MAURA O'BRIEN: We
stayed up all night,
and we climbed to the top
of the football stadium.
We watched the sun rise.
Being very still, it
was really beautiful.
LUKAS GAFFNEY:
The third class we
did in Panama was the
biology of coral reefs.
And I remember the first day
of class, we got on a boat.
We went to a deserted
island called
Cubita, kind of in
the middle of nowhere,
off the coast of Panama.
And then, we spent six
hours that day snorkeling,
and six hours every day after
that snorkeling as a class.
MARGARET WANG: I was president
of the Chinese Student
Association, and we
just did a banquet,
in which we invited
a YouTube star.
And then it started
snowing so hard
that we couldn't drive him back.
But we ended up just
having a snowball fight,
and rolling down the
hill, which is cool,
because you don't get to do
that with a YouTube everyday.
DIANA LIU: My favorite
moments are always
spent in the treehouse
in the Cotsen Children's
Library in Firestone.
STEVE SERVER: Any
time that all of us
who were in my Z
group as freshmen
get to spend time together.
SARINA HUANG: Performing with
my dance company every year.
AVNEESH SARWATE: Playing in
the concert with the Princeton
Laptop Orchestra.
MENGYI XU: For the Pre-Rade
leading in the class of 2017.
ERISA APANTAKU: We all
climbed Mount Kenya,
which is the second
largest peak in Africa.
RYAN MCCARTY: Singing for
the Nassoon alumni
at reunions.
ELLEN TUNG: Between my
junior and senior year,
after eight months of
hard work, I finally
submitted my paper to a
professional research journal.
LUKE PAULSEN: A couple
weeks into freshman year,
I'm in wind ensemble in
the low brass section,
with a couple of my friends.
We decided, then and there, the
back row of the wind ensemble,
to start our own brass ensemble.
And now, we've been
playing for four years.
NATASHA JAPANWALA:
Being a member
of the Edwards Collective.
I've met some of my best
friends through this program.
I'm going to think
of all the moments
that we just spent
together, talking
about art and philosophy
and all the things we love.
And developing in the process,
these fabulous friendships
that I really do think are
going to last a lifetime.
[MUSIC PLAYING]